[Music]
it's a family affair the kardashian crew
stepping out to support kylie jenner's
latest cosmetics launch
[Applause]
looks like kylie is feeling the love and
we feel like proud parents as the beauty
mogul celebrates the lip kits that
started it all i am so in love with the
lip blush lip kits they are my favorite
thing
the woman of the hour looked like the
billionaire she is in an all-white
corset mini dress at the event in l.a
and she brought along her mini-me stormy
who coordinated with her mom in a
futuristic silver look okay she's the
cool one and while all eyes were on
kylie her superstar sisters and mom
brought their fashion a game too
kim sizzled in a skin-tight black
jumpsuit paired with a valenciaga
handbag and thigh-high boots and she
never misses a moment to strike a pose
you're gonna know your angle model of
the fam kendall jenner strutted her
stuff in a colorful slip dress fit for
summer while courtney arrived in all
black with her rocker bow travis barker
looking like a sexy punk rock princess
[Music]
taxi in the back i love you
like mother like daughter chloe matched
with momager kris jenner both rocking
chic pink pantsuits
which was perfectly on trend for the all
pink theme inside the event
[Music]
we're talking custom kylie cocktails and
a signature rise and shine pink lemonade
drink
rise and shine
safe to say kylie didn't skimp on the
blush details for her guest with kylie
candy machines and arcade games
including this pink skee-ball game it's
always so much fun but of course kylie
had her beauty goodies on display for
guests to grab on the go
yup kylie cosmetics coming straight out
of custom vending machines i love it
kylie's launch appeared to be a hit and
we're sure to see more family nights out
on the kardashians season two premiering
in september especially kylie's journey
after baby number two i need my first
night out i haven't had a night out in
almost a year no matter how crazy things
are
we're always gonna be family
[Music]
you